hi shelby
hi steve
how are you
or i'm doing well or should i say come
on
uh so
we should always take advantage of these
to say
make sure everyone maintains their
social distancing
and wears a mask
i get mad at our health authorities here
in canada they don't come up with a very
strong statement on mass they always say
well if you can't maintain social
distancing then you should wear a mask i
just think wearing a mask all the
evidence increasingly is that wearing a
mask if both people wear masks
the
possibility of transmission is
significantly reduced
so
yeah that's what research is showing
yeah yep i'm here stand inside my house
i always go out to go to the store and i
wear a mask yeah i mean we want to get
out more and more and my wife and i we
go out and play golf and we don't wear
masks while playing golf and we have we
even had dinner on the outdoor patio at
the golf club but i'm not going inside
the restaurant
and it's and i'm going to be going to
the bank now i'll go to the store i wear
a mask when i go inside anything and
it's it's just makes sense for myself
and for others so
you know yeah
so we had a little bit of propaganda
just to encourage good practices
everywhere
uh now so how's your french learning
been
so it's been good but i do admit that
this week i have spent less time reading
than i planned on and i haven't even
really been practicing pronouncing words
out loud
um i've been listening to
different lessons and songs but
um yeah not so much of the reading and
practicing pronunciation so
i think like when i do
say words out loud they don't come out
the way i think they're gonna come out
right so i feel like i have a long way
to go there and i i just didn't commit
as much time this week as i should have
what uh what i'm going to do
is first i wanted to say that that's
normal
that the easiest thing so that's not
necessarily bad
because the easiest thing to do is to
listen
and the listening kind of keeps us in
touch with the language we're learning
even when we don't have as much time as
we would like to have to do other things
so
sometimes i do less reading on my ipad
less linking because of
you know other activities
but as long as i can get some listing in
it keeps me in touch with the language
so
and that's where you know the playlist
is so useful because i can put
the whole course on a playlist or you
know put lessons onto a playlist and
i've always got it with me to listen to
that was my one comment the only comment
you know you made was that you think
when you're reading you think that
you've got the pronunciation when you go
to say it you don't pronounce it
properly that's also perfectly normal
and uh i find that i do the same so if
i'm listening to arabic or something and
while i'm listening to it and i i sorry
when i read it and i've listened to that
text and i think i'm i've got the
pronunciation i'm pronouncing it to
myself in my head but when i actually go
to say it of course i don't pronounce it
as well
you know in real like
out loud as i do to myself in my brain
and but what i have found with other
languages is that it's just a question
of time the more you continue listening
and reading
uh when you eventually go to pronounce
things three months from now six months
from now you'll just do a lot better
than you do now
so i think it's very important that you
have a sense that you feel that you're
in your mind that you're pronouncing it
correctly that means that you're hearing
it
even if you can't produce it it doesn't
matter
okay but let's maybe we should go into a
lesson and hear you pronounce
and see how that goes would you say that
right now pronunciation is your main
concern rather than any particular issue
of grammar
in terms of my main concern um i would
say it's my weakest point out of you
know the four main buckets um but
my biggest concern i still
do think i'm
um
not fully
adept in the um
sentence structure and
i mean like you gave me a great lesson
on on
last week
which
at the time i wasn't fully understanding
and then actually when i rewatched the
video and then re-read some of the
lessons i got it a lot better so
grammar and sentence structure is like
kind of coming together but i don't feel
actually super comfortable stringing
together a sentence even okay well let's
uh let's have a look at uh another mini
story then
okay cool
all right so you want to do a mini story
whatever what's up to you you're in
charge you want to do a mini story on
lepti pass last week we did let's do
le
lopez
oops
what's interesting when we say lupti
pass
i said last time that in french you have
this o sound right which speakers of
spanish are inclined to want to say le
petit
when in fact it's le petit right
and so the word petit often the uh
almost disappears
so sometimes you'll see in a book
where it's quite colloquial they'll say
le and then p apostrophe
tends to kind of disappear anyway
let's go sentence mode so people can see
the uh
yeah okay that we don't need okay
all right so maybe we could start by
reading it
okay
let's give this give this a shot
get right to your permission
okay
very good very good
so let's first deal with the
pronunciation issues the first one
is
and and i this is very important because
you can explain something to someone
that person can understand what you're
explaining that doesn't mean that
becomes a habit
so we talked about the liaison
so i know
i know i'm failing on the liaison i know
that so that's okay that's okay and and
very often when you notice you and you
may i often make a mistake and then i i
realize that i made that mistake after
the fact and that's very good because we
need to make mistakes eventually we
actually notice ourselves making the
mistake and then at some point we stop
making the mistake but it's not like an
automatic you do something or i do
something i say something wrong someone
corrects me and now i'm doing it
correctly that's not how it works
gradually we get better at it so joe
dumont pardon you said that fines
on phone so we have to hear this uh
was fine that was good
yeah
right so there again because it's
there's a o there so even if you don't
pronounce the uh we have to hear the d
whereas if it's masculine
then we don't hear the d
except if it begins with a ball
so
right there there is a liaison if that
was um it would be agrantum
okay but
but if it's uh
a big book a great book
we don't hear the d
so the liaison issue
so there's a number of letters that are
silent if the next word begins with a
consonant
uh
but there is this liaison issue if we
ever come across where like if the d
then is followed by a word that begins
with a
vowel
then the d is accentuated it almost
sounds like yeah but you wouldn't have a
gonda but
uh yeah
so okay so could we say that yeah
my thought is just like
i understood that the liaison is kind of
like a
i understand that there's there's actual
words like this that are um
compressed are these called compound
words in french as well
contractions i think it's a contraction
okay maybe i don't know i i don't have
so many terms i don't know many terms
it's not the important part of the
special language but the oh it
disappears they are disappears
right so there's these words that are um
kind of connected depending on the
circumstances right um i also kind of
understood that the
liaison is right really between every
word like maybe and maybe that wasn't
what you taught me directly but i saw in
one of your videos that in french it's
really monotonous and it's just kind of
like this long string and there's not so
much of a separation between each word
true and i think to some extent every
foreign language sounds that way when
you get started but
in particular though
it's this idea that words that begin
with a vowel or h
uh that the
consonant that precedes that word
is kind of carried on so je de mon paul
don't
fall so you have to say ozal
found the word that is the ds so leave a
grand
person
excellent you hit every one of the nasal
sounds
because that's an issue yes that's an
issue in french because there's a
tendency to confuse them
so and what's also very nice is uh you
sound like you're uh
a hispanic person
better than sounding like an american
speaker well not necessarily but that's
not necessary but that's fine
i've got some french friends and i've
been watching some great french videos
too and
i think you know it's all generalization
but i have the
understanding that um americans sound
especially dumb when they speak french
according to french people
i don't think that that's okay
all right the worst thing i think an
english speaker forget american like if
you have english speakers because in
english we tend to have a lot of
intonation like
you know we talk about chinese being a
tonal language english is quite tonal
not in terms of the meaning of each word
but we you know in expressing our
emotions i don't really think that and
there's a lot of intonation and if you
start applying english intonation to
french then it's not good
yeah and that's
that's me right here very exciting no no
you're hispanic now so that's okay
any word in there that uh you're going
to leave deidia or you want you know
so
i understand
it it's just the um
the tense of the word okay
so
so
the thing of it is is wherever you see
the e with the apostrophe the a
apostrophe that's the past
tense past participle right
[Music]
so if you had
dda
ier at the end that would be the
infinitive to dedicate
right
so this one this is the past participle
i dedicated
so that's the past participle it's the
same as dedicated in english right
okay so the other thing that i would say
there is
pardo
because we don't demand pardon faith
yeah it's a common phrase and it's
apologizes how it's
translated or i ask forgiveness or
whatever yeah
so but judo
it's it's it's a it's not that useful
you don't spend so much of your life
apologizing but um
would that be like for example if say
i'm
in paris lost and i need to say like
excuse me
if you've done something bad you might
say mcdonald's okay you know if you
spilled their coffee cup or something
but no
morning okay there you go if you spell
your own that's okay you don't have to
apologize
okay all right all right next line yeah
um
very good
very good
um
every so often you slip into the
e
army
oh a u is always
so the double l is kind of like the
double l in spanish in this sense right
like
like it isn't
the word fee
fee yeah it's always i mean there there
are some exceptions where the double l
is pronounced as l typically in names
but overwhelmingly it's it's uh
i mean
i mean you know a million but if it's uh
mostly it's double l is like is is uh
like a y okay okay
mayor
mayer
mayor and that's it's not quite the
spanish is a little
especially if you're in argentina they
get a stronger version but it's mayor
yes
but
mayor mayer
no yeah okay
and so you have
bong is good
mayor
is better and le mayor is the best so i
would save le mayer because it's often
useful to know
how uh you know
the superlative you know is is is done
in different languages
so okay so but yeah
there's
it's the same word medium
but then the only difference is you add
from better to best right
so there's no separate word for better
better is is mayer
okay see now you know it's better so
save my year
should it what do you think about i
don't like that that's this that you
don't to me
less is more
okay so lumber is it's kind of useful
and uh again it's important to
distinguish between adjectives and
adverbs
you know
is the adverb we won't get into that now
but mayure
is is the adjective
is the best player the mayor
the mayor
okay so
unexcused
all right
any of those sounds that are difficult
and uh or even distinguishing the
different nasal sounds you have to
remember that you will only get better
as you continue to listen
and then you read and you kind of sell
vocal eyes
and yes when you go to pronounce it you
still don't get it quite you don't
really nail it but you will continue
gradually get better that the brain
starts to sort these things out and get
more and more as it hears the sounds
better it's you're gonna slowly be able
to pronounce them better but it all
takes time
okay and a u is o boku a u o
ho
o is a right
or is this is a contraction so
a la if it was a feminine
i don't know
but here is
becomes
all right so that's important to
remember o is al
combined in one word and it becomes full
yeah it's not the most intuitive but
it's not a tall intuitive
it's dumb
why did it do it that way
but that's how they do it so we have to
get used to the language as it is not as
we would like it to be
all right i'll play along all right
okay no let's try that all right can we
page yes please
all right
because if there's no vowel there
we don't hear the second t there so it's
two
two component
and say the last part
perfect perfect
and you understand that right uh-huh
yeah i don't know why
this is
you don't need
i know what that means and also you know
what i'm fine
yes i do i i don't know so what level is
this at i don't really need to practice
that
and call me actually i know
i know all of these yeah i think
actually i'm like i said i was just
listening so i haven't been reading so i
haven't been organizing my links that's
fine i find that
i like to
get rid of the colored you know blue or
yellow words on my page because one of
the signs to me that i'm improving in
the language because very often we have
the impression that we're not improving
yeah but if i see my page getting whiter
and wider
uh that gives me the sense that i'm
getting better because
yeah i like seeing the stats go up okay
that's a very
yeah did you say you wanted to look at
my stats today
we could i didn't say that but we could
do so if you want it's up to you
um
i'm enjoying this but it's just keeping
that's very motivating yeah okay okay
next page
all right
okay i have never said this word before
okay
okay
we'll stop you there
yeah the s
almost always is pronounced like a zed
when it's between
two
two vowels
[Music]
excuse
perfect
so the r to the t r that gets wrapped
into the wah
yeah yeah
okay
[Laughter]
okay
first of all
ooh so i was thinking you know i should
make some sentences before they go
because that is difficult until you get
used to it so oh you is always going to
be
whereas the u all by itself is
yeah but here it's of course how is this
one pronounced
um
ooh ooh absolutely because it's oh you
oh
yeah one thing to note that some people
who are learning french if there is an
accent on the u here it's it means where
where right whereas but doesn't that
change the pronunciation not at all not
in this case that's so weird not in this
case
i don't know what the origin of the word
is
but if with the accent there it means
where and if there's no accent it means
or
right
more or less
more or less
in that case there's no accent on the u
okay
these are all things i don't
anything i say is simply background
noise helps you notice it it might be i
might mention this again and all of a
sudden one day you'll look at it and
you'll see there's a new there with no
accent and it means or and if it has an
accent it means where
now abit
what do you think abit means
oh to live yeah okay very good i knew
that and then you said okay now here
again
i say that there's a liaison with a
consonant if the next word begins with a
vowel but it's not always the case
so here
fun is always fun i've never heard
anyone say femme
for whatever reason maybe we have a
native speaker here who will chime in
and tell us but to me it's elephant
she is hungry
so
in
when i was at school we were learning
french and so there were certain
expressions with avoir
to have avoir has to have right
that's to have
all right now there are certain column
idiomatic expressions that use the uh
use a technical term auxiliary verb
is to be hungry
is to be called
is to want to do something
has to be afraid so you'll come across
more and more of these where the word
like
is used together with
hunger thirst
cold
fear and so forth mm-hmm
yeah to have hunger to have fear have
have cold
right the
good thing is spanish prepared me well
for this one but that was so that was
very hard to overcome when i first
started learning spanish so
if you don't speak a language that does
that structures
this kind of phrase like this it takes a
while it takes a while and even after
it's explained and yeah that makes sense
uh you still want to say josephus yeah
totally
in spanish or in french and it's just
one of these things that
sorry and you know how in spanish you
can say you know uh tengo frio but you
could also say
estoy con frio
could you do the same thing in french no
just sweet
i've never heard it maybe there are some
areas in france where they say or quebec
i've never heard french speakers leave
your comments
leave some comments i'm not aware of it
so one thing i would say that for people
who do multiple romance languages
even languages as close as spanish and
portuguese there's always differences in
not only in usage but in in grammar
minor differences yeah
they're very similar there's a you can't
assume that because it works one way in
the one romance language it'll work the
same in the other
and i mean even the the sentence
structure um between
spanish and portuguese is very different
and like the one that keeps on getting
me in french is
yeah there's a slightly different
sentence structure and having to say the
article as well i'm having to say the
article right yeah that i'm getting
stuck on yep absolutely
okay we go for another sentence here
um
so first of all we have another
idiomatic expression with
the auxiliary verb
to have ella
she needs
so that's a very very common expression
and
you know need
need is is something we are often
expressing to want to need uh is one of
these things that we often have to say
so jay boswan
that's quite useful
okay
do something we have a need of something
buzz wanna do
and in this case what does she have a
need for
to be comforted right or consult
consoled yeah i mean comforted consoles
the same
and can you start can you read the
sentence again
okay so elaborate
but make sure buzzword
it takes a long time to get used to the
fact that the unaccentuated e in french
is most often uh
it's not a and that's particularly the
case for speakers of other romance
languages they want to go beswan but
it's bizwa
and it's dead
dead there's no accent on the last er so
the last er can actually disappear
right
and one last thing which we won't get
into detail on but we want to start
noticing these things you notice there's
an extra e on console
right because she's a female exactly
okay
uh so that's the past participle and the
past participle will always agree
with
the subject sen yeah exactly so if
there's the reason i the way i learned
that is because i noticed the the word
fiancee
i mean which we use in english of course
right is sometimes filled with two e's
and sometimes with one and i i had to do
some research years ago and i thought
okay one day when i learned french i'll
remember this here we go
right
okay so maybe we take one more sentence
[Music]
oh good we got a lot of blue words here
great well
we already know i know this one right
except it's again one of the things in
link is we we count each form of the
word as a separate word so even if you
know the word excuse when it shows up as
a plural which is the s here
then we count it again as a word very
often it performs differently in the
sentence in this case it doesn't
but that's why you can't do too much
bragging about your word count in link
because it counts every form of the word
yeah well and of course i could have um
hit the x and ignored that i got a
little bit
no i wouldn't do that keyboard i
wouldn't call i don't ignore different
forms of a word i only ignore
uh you could i mean it's your own
statistic you can do whatever you want
but if it's a proper noun or name of a
place or something then i ignore it but
different form of a word i count that
okay cool yeah because in some cases you
might for example a different form of a
verb you might have trouble with that
particular form of the verb
you know and uh
so no i i it's legitimate to count each
form of a word in my opinion as a
separator
okay let's try reading it
all right
excuse
and of course the s the second s we
don't pronounce right
so c
says
exclusive
excuse right we pronounce the first s or
not that's the second actually c2 says
excuse there's a liaison c2 says excuse
me
now we come to the verb
now do you know what
the meaning is first of all
this verb no no no that's that's
the excuses that's enough this
so
this is like to be sufficient correct
to be enough right yeah yeah so to
suffice i guess that's it
so you know you mentioned earlier
well that you know we don't you we have
to use the personal pronoun in french
one of the reasons is that the third
person plural for example
for some verbs can sound the same as the
third person singular in other words the
e and t
of that
they form is never pronounced
so right
now the third person singular in this
case is sufi
but there are verbs where the third
person's singular
and the third person plural can sound
the same in any case enough of the
different forms sound the same that we
always need the personal pronoun
so situ says excuse me
which you understand right right okay
you want me to say it
no you can continue reading okay
[Music]
so
right a little bit complicated
but uh
is is a useful expression
did i say that right
i am willing
but it means more than uh
has lots of different meanings you'll
come across it again in different
contexts that's why i think it's worth
saving
so it says i'm willing i'd like that
did you want another cup of coffee
it has lots of different
uh you know lots of different meanings
i'd be happy yeah
yeah by the way i see you use context
reversal that's my go-to dictionary in
different languages
yeah i actually haven't been using it
that much but since you recommended it i
um need to start using it and it also
has a context reversal has a conjugating
dictionary which is also very very good
i love that yeah that's very helpful
so it's kind of like another uh way of
saying like i want to but it's a little
bit more
it can mean
a slightly different
it means all of those things and more
like i don't mind i wouldn't mind
i want to uh gladly uh you know all of
those things in fact
click on the three dots we'll get even
more
i could go down to that okay yeah
you know so it's a very useful phrase
you're going to hear it again all right
let's get back to our text
so and did ye we've already come across
but here of course it's in the
infinitive whereas last time was the
past particle right
i see oh yeah you're adding uh more
hints to your dictionary definition
that's great
i am yeah just because there weren't
really very many good ones so sorry i
missed what you said
no that the next word you know the ada
we've already had yeah
just a different form of that word so
did i mark that other one as known or i
don't remember i wanna i wanna review
that okay
okay
sir
right
this is where this sentence just gets
destroyed for me let me try it's so
convoluted
okay
uh it has kaite
that has
yeah that has because if it's not it's
not love ki
which would be who
it's kind of
awkward it would
be key
right it's just that it's turning this
into it's just like who has or that has
kind of the same difference right right
yeah it's really the same difference
it's yeah you know centigrade trying to
be clever i think i don't know
now do you know the word
no
oh
all right that's a useful word
yeah i like that and that like another
time yeah okay yeah formally in the past
another time exactly
but it doesn't mean the same as ultravet
in spanish no
no so be careful of the what they call
the false
friends or something
yeah for me
you're right uh
so it's just to bear in mind that if
it's kaitei
that he wants to use that as the object
rather than them
okay
so i have trouble sorry my way through
this but
not okay
i mean this is a weird like mystery well
i think if he said if he said
it has a slightly different meaning
uh
in other words
the child who
used to be this great person
that was one thing spoke to the child
that was once that great person
so
and as you read this book too all of
this context makes more sense because
they talk so much about ron person like
the
great people
um
and
and children and you know it's about the
child have you read this book
uh bits and pieces yeah
yeah i like history books anyway i think
this is this is the object that kaiete
is the object of dede
so he's dedicating the book to the child
and i think that the the
day
is still the object of the dedication
so it's not ki ayate
would almost separate
the latter half of the sentence but here
he say i'm dedicated to the child
who used to be this is the child he used
to be this
great person so it's sort of the object
of the dedication that's why it's
rather than
okay
okay since we've tied ourselves in knots
here
maybe that's good enough for today
and uh we'll save your statistics for
next time because i think we've covered
it and uh keep on doing what you're
doing
uh keep on listening and and reading and
sometimes
the ooh and the
uh
it's kind of maybe at some point
occasionally practice them just to get
used to saying them even if you get them
wrong
focus on the listening and the reading
and you'll find that in two three months
from now
it won't be so much of a of a tongue
twister to uh to get to hit these sounds
you know
to get them right
that it's i've had the experience so
many times that what i find very
difficult to pronounce at the beginning
if i keep on listening and reading three
months three months four or five months
down the road i'm able to pronounce them
much better because my brain hears them
better
and
you can't pronounce what you can't hear
so
you've got to train the brain to get
used to them and then pretty soon you
start to be able to produce them
very true
i look forward to that all right so uh
we'll leave it at that then and uh
hopefully this is helpful to people and
uh we look forward to your comments
merci beaucoup steve
balcou
okay bye-bye
bye
[Music]
you